[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right let me bring in dockitch
espn college basketball analyst host of
the dan dockett show
on the fan in indianapolis let me start
there do you think
michigan would rather win the national
championship in basketball
or beat ohio state this november in
football
dan i look i have a son that went to
michigan
i paid a lot of money to michigan
there's no
look a national championship is a banner
that's hanging there's no doubt winning
a national championship in football i
mean
damn i realize ohio state can't or
excuse me michigan can't remember the
last time they beat
ohio state and football but come on
there's banners
for winning a national championship
that's forever nobody
five years from now nobody remembers the
score of the ohio state michigan game
come on
it feels like it feels like it's it's a
story for a week when you win a national
championship
but the bragging rights of beating ohio
state in football
you're a basketball guy you're in
indiana what do you know about football
hey i know from football pal i know from
football tom allen in indiana we're
rolling
football you're better than michigan you
are
you are all right what's the big story
line you take away
so far from march madness uh dan i i
take away a couple things i take away
the big ten
uh big ten losing eight of nine and
doing it badly
you know i've always said the big ten
and i don't know if you agree with this
or not but coaches will tell you man the
big 10's best coach league big 10's best
scouted league
yeah there's some bad coaching in this
tournament in the big ten and i hate to
say it because most of these guys are my
friends
dan i'm watching purdue go down can't
make a shot and they got their two best
shooters on the sideline i'm watching
edie
who play great not even get off the
bench i'm watching michigan state go
down
and they got their two best shooters on
the sideline hauser and gabe brown i'm
watching illinois i'm at the illinois
game the other day big d
and they don't adjust my brother who is
a
attorney he's like why don't they
president why aren't they doing
something i said watch
they will in the last three to five
minutes they did
it didn't matter i look i i think the
big ten iowa didn't guard all year
iowa looked incredibly slow i thought
the big ten looked incredibly slow
uh i take that away and i take that you
know what dan the other thing defense
wins a little bit
like you know um i'm watching and i know
they were way over matched abilene
christian was way over matched against
texas dan
would you agree with this can i ask you
a question yeah
you watch basketball you learn at the
feet of me when i do games i get that
dan
yeah um you ever seen a
more over matched team physically than
abilene christian
and texas and that team wins the game
not
loses wins the game you ever seen a more
overmatched physically team
i probably have but uh just
just the the recent memory of seeing
that was pretty stunning
it was so i i do i think you know you're
here in the big ten you got nine teams
in
you got one left and they all failed
miserably like didn't lose to gonzaga in
the tournament the big ten is i think
the biggest story around here
and then if you look like loyola is not
a cinderella story
oh syracuse isn't a cinderella story no
oral roberts is a cinderella story
uh is oregon state a cinderella story is
ucla a cinderella story
dan we're old enough i don't care what
happens with ucla that's nice
it does sound strange to say that with
ucla but
i mean recent history though i mean
cronin's done a really nice job in there
uh is usc a cinderella story
no i think usc is a redemption story i
think you know when you looked at usc
all you've seen is
you know involvement if you've really
paid attention in that trial
their name came up a lot tony bland's
name came up a lot i think it's
redemption story i think oregon state's
a great story
i think you know wayne tinkle has got
you know he had his son was a good
really good player you know he's gone
all of a sudden they catch fire and
that's
obviously dan as you and i both know
that's one of the great things about the
tournament is you can catch fire
and i think it's a great story i think
ucla is a story of what should be
like ucla should be there and i think
mick cronin
i was talking to michael lewis their
assistant and that's all they talk about
like look at these banners this is what
we should be this is who we
should be dan so i think they're all
great stories in different ways
i mentioned uh the mobley story at usc
this has happened before many times down
down through the years where
you hire somebody if the dad and then
you're able to bring in
uh players and it's totally above board
correct yeah yeah i mean hey look you go
back
i mean whether it's a high school bob
knight back in 76
i mean you'll remember the names john
laskowski and tom abernathy he hired
their high school coach bob donovan
now i don't know if he hired him to get
those two guys but this has been ted
owens did it at kansas for years danny
manning
now this has been going on for years you
know i i never presume
because dan i was in this for 20
some years in coaching and look
everybody said everybody tells me that
everybody cheats right
everything that happens well they cheat
i don't know that anybody i've never had
anybody come up to me and say hey coach
uh they just gave me thirty thousand
dollars i've never had that so
look you hire a guy's dad uh you got the
players you want and away you go it
doesn't have to be nefarious yeah and i
just said that like ed manning got hired
danny manning went there
uh right we saw that with uh michael
porter senior
michael porter jr going to missouri like
that this has happened down through the
years
i think people are just being
reintroduced to it when
you know mobley the mobleys go there to
usc and their dad's on the staff
yeah and and you know we forget the past
so quickly right and the other thing is
here's the one thing man dan when you
were in college and i was in college you
had
three assistant coaches maybe a fourth
guy was a volunteer
now you look at those benches damn
there's 800 dudes in suits and
shoes man i mean
so you know what job you're hiring them
for i don't
know and i'm not just talking about this
situation i'm talking about other
situations you know what job you
there's so many jobs on the bench now
look they hired them they're smart
they're in the sweet 16. let me tell you
something
at indiana right now we'd love to have
the dad of somebody on the sideline and
being the sweet street team
you kidding me uh so who's getting the
indiana job
i don't know who will get it and who
should get it
are those two different questions alfred
should get the job
um my opinion you're asking me yeah okay
yeah
you're not asking a regular fan i've
watched indiana dan for 21 years
since bob knight and the program is in
no better shape
look i know everybody well bob knight
hit a player yeah well
calvin sampson got us on probation yeah
well there was eight million drug tests
or drought
failed drug tests yeah well they haven't
won close the graduation rate isn't any
higher donors aren't it
the basketball's awful and every time i
look in assembly hall and i go into
assembly hall and i see statues you know
where they're from
the bob knight era i've had enough
personally
i've had enough personally of the hot
guy dan
swear to god i called fred glass the ad
when they hired archie miller
and i said you just made the worst hire
you could possibly make
i said you are making us like everybody
else and frankly indiana is like
everybody else
nobody not a lot of great teams how do
you mean that though
how do i mean what that you're like
everybody else well here's what i'm
saying there's not a lot of great teams
and there's not a lot of awful teams
there's a ton of teams right in the
middle
we have no hey dan for 21 years i
thought tom did a really good job karina
bringing this out but we have no
identity
what's indiana basketball about is it
shooting no is it defense no is it tough
play no it's just another team
and for a guy like me dan that spent 17
years there
like i got to get a hip replacement
because of a hit i took i got to get a
knee replacement i got a bad neck
i want to see an indiana guy in there i
want somebody that can bring back
indiana basketball's pride i want to see
somebody that can galvanize a fan base
and frankly
the only guy that i see that can do that
is alfred i get
that the hot guy just won a game and
goes into sweet 16. you know what sold
archie miller
but as you know everybody wins a date
everybody wins a date so i'm tired of
the hot guy here
i'll support him hey look i got a radio
show i'll do everything for the guy
but i'm tired of the hot guy i'm tired
of the
the calvin sampson comes in for crying
out loud was on probation when indiana
hired
on probation in indiana hires him in
indiana then you get a guy well he went
to the final four with dwyane wade
great and tom did a really good job then
you get a guy well he went to the elite
eight who cares
you either can know indiana understand
it's a different job
or you can't and to this point in my
life in my way of thinking
it's been 21 years of the hot guy the
outside guy
how's that worked out for us indiana not
very good he's dan dockett he has been
college basketball analyst and uh has
his own show
the fan in indianapolis we had rick
pitino on last week
and i asked him if this was his final
stop
and uh he said yes and and my danette
said
no it's not his final stop i'm the one
guy who said
this is pitino's final stop all right
dockage
what side you on does patina
does he have another job i had patino on
my show
and coach said this is my final stop
and dan when people tell me things
i listen real close i
i'm on i'm in between but i always say
gun to head
gun to head i say this is his final stop
i'm not sure though when he said it i
believed it
but dan let's think about this rick
pitino ending his career at iona
i like iona iona is great the gaels jeff
rulin yey ron go fight win
but he's gonna end his career at iona
i'm taking the coach at his word
but i ain't betting on it let's put it
that way yeah
i i hope he's found happiness after what
he went through
and now he understands you got a job
back
you got some respect back you go to the
tournament
but egos ego's with you coaches man
hey dan can i ask you a question about
rick pitino all right
do you think rick pitino's like
resume is now
as good if not better than any other
than maybe
you know wooden and shishevsky and
here's why
he leaves in disgrace he goes out to
greece and wins two championships
like that's hard to do man that's
like people don't understand the level
of play then he comes back to this
school
and guess what he takes him to the
tournament i would argue that these last
two years have done nothing but enhance
this man's resume to the point of
jumping a lot of people dan what do you
think
i think he's one of the top five coaches
and i'm talking about nba
and college i today i think pitino is
that good now he's not for everybody a
lot of stops
but the man can coach a basketball game
if you were an indiana fan right now
would you want rick pitino i was going
to ask you that question
here's what i've said give me brad
stevens you know i made this nice
soliloquy
he's not coming he's not okay i know i
know he's not
all right give me brad give me tony
bennett he's turned the job down before
or i'd do a talk show in indy having
rick pitino in bloomington wouldn't be a
bad
it's all about content it's all a little
bit
all about content uh you sent me your
final four i don't think your final four
did too well did it
no my final four stinks i really thought
going into the tournament illinois was
playing as well as anybody including
gonzaga and
dan i was at the illinois game and i'm
telling you illinois didn't have a
chance in that game
like they were not good enough they
didn't move the ball
dan the difference between loyola's
movement
in illinois was it's astounding
dan when here's the other thing okay
you know that crowd wig kid right you're
down
whatever they're comfortable as hell
they just throw it to this guy
he stands at the top of the key surveys
looks around says oh what the hell am i
going to do i'll throw it to you you'll
get a layup
and the other thing and this is where uh
loyola's dangerous
they guard you like they've got
williamson that maybe
if you know it seems like every year a
duke player wins defensive player of the
year i think it's defensive player of
the year sponsored by duke
but the best defensive player is this
williamson kid dan he locks it up
did they name that did they name the
defensive player of the year award after
uh woj
stevo jones i i think they did like all
you gotta do is slap the floor
i think illinois slapped the floor three
times against loyola and loyola scored
all three times when they slapped the
floor
how silly is that you got hey look it's
one thing to slap the floor because
that's what you are
it's another thing to say ah hell i
think i'll slap the floor and act like
i'm playing two sets
hey another thing yeah dan
when i look at oral roberts tom moore
you know the name tom moore
often awesome um assistant coach in the
nfl like should be in the hall of fame
everybody says yeah
tom moore always says players not plays
like late in the game players not plays
these two guys always say the guy's name
from absmus
and o'banner these two dudes got 59
against ohio state now ohio state
pretty good on the perimeter defensively
they got 59 they backed it
up with 55. dan you and i both know the
name harold archambault
and the various guys across the country
over the years that just go nuts
they got two guys that are balling so
yes
oral roberts is a damn uh they are a
cinderella
but when you got two guys that are going
like that
against florida against ohio state you
gotta take them serious
you gotta take them very serious it's
always great to talk to you
you're the best thanks for the texts
yeah well
you're kind of lonely can i do a plug
we're shameless
oh god okay that saturday mornings
i do a show on siriusxm radio 84 84.
it's combination basketball and stern
it's unbelievable
wait did you just call yourself
unbelievable
i said the show's unbelievable yeah it's
unbelievable sirius gave you a job
that's the unbelievable and i saw your
dog you're just a lonely man
you you're brackets and a dog i'm in a
basement dan i'm in a basement with my
iu memorabilia i just sit here and
dream of the day i kick michael jordan's
ass you know what i mean dan that's what
i do all day
did you name your dog knight
alfred uh
no damon bailey
i named it calbert uh
good to talk to you bud you too thanks
for having me that's
dan dockage he works at the mothership
and of course
the dan dockage show on the fan in
indianapolis